el tiempo de negociación ya comenzó 577
escaños del parlamento están en juego en
junio la tercera ronda de votaciones
comienza esta noche
marine lepén y jean-luc mélenchon se han
lanzado a la batalla para influir en la
forma en que se gobierna francia e
impulsar sus políticas pero ellos y
otros partidos no podrán lograrlo si
cada uno se presenta en solitario
y
hablar de partidos de oposición
mayoritarios no tiene sentido si no
tienen alianzas pero si hay alianzas de
un lado y del otro no todo puede pasar
en los parlamentos elegidos por voto
proporcional los partidos tienen varios
diputados que reflejan su índice de
apoyo pero el parlamento francés es
elegido por mayoría de votos lo que
significa que cada diputado necesita
alcanzarla por eso la organización de un
líder popular como jean-luc mélenchon
sólo tiene 17 diputados de 577 las
alianzas podrían permitir que los
partidos obtengan una parte justa de los
escaños los líderes de izquierda todavía
están tratando de ponerse de acuerdo
sobre cómo formar una alianza mélenchon
quiere que los socialistas que son de
centroizquierda compartan su plataforma
de extrema izquierda lo que según los
informes se niegan a hacer mientras
tanto en la extrema derecha lepén
considera que ese muro tuvo una extraña
forma de buscar una reconciliación
durante la noche electoral
si la juve
esa es la octava vez que un lepén pierde
una batalla
[Música]
los seguidores del epen dicen que se
debería cambiar de tono y quieren seguir
adelante para llegar a un acuerdo desde
que las elecciones legislativas se
celebran justo después de la votación
presidencial los mandatarios electos
siempre han conseguido una mayoría en el
parlamento